- [Voiceover] Many 18th and 19th century
Romantic poets were believers in rebellion
against social conventions,
express strong emotion, and
the power of imagination.
So, spider-sense is already sensing
something a little bit off.
So we're talking about many 18th
and 19th century Romantic poets.
So we're talking about poets,
so the poets were believers in rebellion
against social conventions,
and express strong emotions.
So, this is strange,
because the first part
of this, we're listing
the things that they did.
So the poets were believers in rebellion
against social conventions,
and they expressed strong emotions,
or were believers in rebellion against
social conventions,
expressed strong emotions,
so what's really troubling here,
why this feels off, is that this,
the were believers, were,
this is in the past.
This is in the past right over here.
While express right over here,
this is in the present.
So, the verb tense is off.
We're definitely talking about stuff
in the past, 18th and 19th
century Romantic poets.
So all of these statements about them
should be in the past.
So it should be, were
believers in rebellion
against social conventions,
expressed strong emotions,
and the power...
I guess, express strong emotions,
and the power of imagination.
So even this is a little bit strange.
So let's just read the different choices.
So we don't like it as is,
so let's rule out A.
It's unchanged, as the
underlined part unchanged,
so let's look at the other choices.
Many 18th and 19th century Romantic poets
are believers...
So this is in the present,
but clearly, we're talking about things
that happened in the past.
18th and 19th century poets,
so we're going to rule this out,
we don't like this
happening in the present.
Many 18th and 19th century Romantic poets
who believed in rebellion
against social conventions,
express strong emotion.
So once again, we're keeping this part
over here, this is in the present.
Express, it should be expressed.
It should be in the past tense.
We're talking about 18th
and 19th century poets.
So we'll rule that one out.
Many 18th and 19th century Romantic poets
believed in rebellion
against social conventions,
to express strong emotions,
and the power of imagination.
So this is strange,
because they didn't believe
in rebellion against social conventions,
so that they could
express strong emotions.
The meaning here just seems off,
so I hope that this
one reads a lot better.
Many 18th and 19th century Romantic poets
believed in rebellion
against social conventions,
so far, so good, past tense.
The expression of strong emotions,
and the power of imaginations.
So this is really neat, because,
what did the poets believe in?
They believed in,
and once again, it's past
tense, so that's good,
and they believed in three things.
It's very clearly articulated.
They believed in rebellion
against social conventions,
that's the first thing they believed in.
The second thing they believed in is
the expression of strong emotions,
and then the third thing
that they believed in,
was the power of imagination.
So this believed, this past tense,
this action of believing in the past,
this applies to these three clauses.
They believed in rebellion
against social conventions,
the expression of strong emotions,
and the power of the imagination.
What was really kind of bothering me
up here in the original one,
this verb tense, they were believers,
and then they express strong emotion,
and then the power of imagination.
Is this something they're expressing?
If all of these were things that
they were expressing, they should have put
the expressed out front.
For several reasons, this first one
was very strangely formed.
But we really like E.